Be sure to subscribe to Lang Focus and
click the notification button.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is PLA.
Today I want to look at a linguistic
phenomenon that I find interesting.
It's called metathesis.
The word metathesis comes from the Greek
word may talk disease meaning change of
position or transposition.
It refers to a situation in which
adjacent sounds change position in a
word.
For example,
in English we have ask but you might
have also heard acts in some dialects.
You can see that the two consonants have
switched places.
Another example from English,
we have the word asterisk which refers
to this little star looking symbol away,
not that one.
This one.
Some people pronounce it as Asterix.
Another one,
the prefix intro or intra is often
pronounced like inter for example,
introduce is sometimes pronounced
introduce so you can see that the r
sound and the vowel have become
reversed.
Another one,
the prefix pre or pro is often
pronounced like per for example,
prescription becomes prescription.
We can see examples of metathesis of
side-by-sides sound switching positions
in many different languages.
In.
What kinds of situations does this
happen?
Well,
during the development of a language,
there's sometimes a change.
For example,
the English word bird came from.